well we're done with the core of our
content provider but there's still one
more optional method that'll make things
much more efficient
we'll start by hitting ctrl o to look at
the functions we can override it turns
out there's a function called bulk
insert anyone out there who has done
database work knows that putting a bunch
of inserts into a single transaction is
usually much faster than inserting them
individually bulk insert allows us to do
just that the default implementation
just calls insert a bunch of times but
we can wrap it in a transaction if we
implemented ourselves we're only going
to add support for weather forecast
transactions here since they're the only
ones we insert in bulk we start by
calling DB dot begin transaction for
each content values passed in we insert
and update the number of Records
inserted when we're done we set the
transaction to be successful otherwise
our records will not be committed and
then rely on the finally statement to
end the transaction in the default case
we just call the super class remember it
does the insert just not optimally and
that's it that's all we have to do to
implement bulk insert